Dave ribbon lovely to see you you're one
of those guys that have seen so much on
a screen that is that it's refreshing as
you said before to see you finally in
three dimensions three dimensions I can
be poked and touched and I'm real and
this is one with very bizarre this is
one we've got the gap between us and
what obviously going to spend quite a
bit of time talking about the Rubin
report in a second and indeed the way in
which she got there but I just wonder
how it feels to be the interviewee
rather than the interviewer to be
staring down the barrel of the gun
rather than holding the pistol yourself
yeah that might be the question you
should be asking me at the end because
it's so far so far so good yeah I like
doing this I like being on either side
of the interview you know it's like when
I'm doing what I do on the show I
genuinely like sitting across from
someone looking them in the eye and
figuring out what they think I mean you
mentioned a moment ago that you've kind
of moved away from the left or rather or
not that you mean well they got rid of
me and yeah talk about that and yeah you
were apart for a time as though of the
the along with the Young Turks you know
progressive liberals popular progressive
liberals went one has to say what went
wrong that's a good question
yes look I've been a lefty my whole life
I when I first got into politics was
seventh grade it was during the year so
he was amazing 7th or 8th grade during
the dukakis George HW Bush presidential
election and we were running a mock
campaign in my social studies class and
I was working for the Dukakis campaign
that he was the liberal he was the
Democrat and it was so obvious to me
that liberals and Democrats were the
good guys they cared about poor people
they cared about minorities these were
the good guys
Republicans or conservatives were cold
and they only cared about money in taxes
and they didn't care about minorities or
anything like that so my whole life I
mean I voted for Obama twice I was on
The Young Turks a pretty far left
progressive Network I was part of that
thing and one ginger mind I mean there
were a couple moments there were a lot
of things just related to accusations
that I constantly saw coming from my
side that I didn't like so every
argument somehow every one that when
against progressive think was somehow a
racist
bigot or a homophobe or a transfer board
name another phob like everybody and I
thought this can't be right even though
I was surrounded by a lot of people
saying that I thought this can't be
right there have to be people on the
other side of this argument who have
good intentions who are not the worst of
the worst people so that was one thing
that the arguments became really lazy
instead of seeing intellectual arguments
I saw just a lot of accusations and
slandering and slurring can I please
finally tell the truth about why he left
the Young Turks he wanted to make a
six-figure salary to host a 30 minute a
week show when everyone here you know
because we work for an independent news
company was getting paid far less while
working 12 hour days
that's why Dave Rubin left the company
and now all of a sudden he's getting
funded by the Koch brothers and all of a
sudden his opinions are very different
he has no political identity he is not
an honest actor he is not an
intellectual he is a fraud that's who
Dave Rubin is
I mean I mean I wish I knew how she
really felt that's boy where to begin
you know fraud lazy avaricious you know
immoral you wanted more money first off
I never asked from you know it's so
silly to even unfortunately to have to
talk about these little nonsensical
things because I cuz I like talking
about ideas not about people I never
asked for more money that's number one I
left I told them I was leaving and I
left there were no no go to negotiations
that's it actually my my executive
producer who I brought with me they
offered to double his salary if he
stayed so together we would have we
would have made more money if we'd
stayed but that is nothing to do with
nothing I would see them no it's like
it's kind of pathetic really
I'm not funded by the Koch brothers I
mean I wish I was funded by the Koch
brothers that would be nice I wouldn't
be wearing H&M underwear I mean it's
like this is this is this is what I'm
talking about it's that sort of endless
hysteria attacking people attacking
motives nobody's interested in that
anymore I really don't think people are
interested in that well let's talk then
about about the Rubin report hundreds of
thousands potentially millions in fact
of subscribers on YouTube certainly in
terms of views you're way way up there
if you were to describe the program to
someone who'd never seen it before would
you say we're trying to talk about big
ideas in an honest open way that's it I
mean I want to sit with somebody and as
I said before I want to go what what do
you think why do you think it and what
do you really think is wrong right now I
mean something is wrong it is very clear
that within the way that we in the West
right now can discuss ideas something
has gone horrific ly awry we are hat
we're coming to a place where we're just
at loggerheads all the time you feel
that you're positive that under the echo
chamber the use of of of criticized a
number of occasions you look at the
people that you've spoken to regularly
if they do seem to be all largely from
the same political place you mentioned
some highness your Shapiro's your Peter
Samaras and Shapiro disagree on
literally everything I mean there's not
one topic that they agree on existential
issues to abortion to taxes to
everything down the road I wouldn't call
it an echo chamber at all actually
unless maybe I'm misunderstanding the
question but here's a point that yeah
you might disagree with I mean we I'm
down to disagree we can do it
- yeah a similar job I work in the
mainstream media you work elsewhere sure
but we both predominantly are
interviewers I just wonder when you look
back at an hour or two hours in the
company of modeling you're not placing
the Outen Peterson do you actually think
you challenged them enough yeah because
yeah I mean yeah but you you you
generally share their views and I've
talked about it these are ideas that
interest you excite you well Jordans
ideas I genuinely generally do share and
for sure Milo I don't know what his
views are anymore that it's whatever but
I would say that sitting down with these
people the only way you're gonna figure
out what they think is to let them speak
so there's an odd thing now that if you
sit down with someone that that means
you automatically endorse them I just
thought I just don't buy basically probe
something Yahoo and I just wonder
whether that happens I mean okay this is
that this next clip I just want to play
you was produced by someone who is a
self-confessed
fan of the Rubin report but yeah he
produced a little parody and in in canto
Isle of Wight look yeah how does it feel
to be none regressive today Sam at the
present moment the most crucial point
for us to focus on is I agree with that
you didn't let me finish regressive I
agree with that honestly Dave if you
believe that you can just agree with
your guess on everything they say you're
totally I agree with that it's like if
you're not embodying the mythos of the
archetypal hero by metaphorically dying
you're never gonna kill the snake man
let alone rescue your father from the
underworld who has a billion of anything
nobody it's absurd I agree with that
I don't know but I think the shapiro is
absolutely spot-on in that I mean great
was that been actually doing the boys
there well first off I love that I mean
the idea that you know somebody's making
a funny parody video of me that's been
seen by a million people it's like whoa
we must actually be doing something
that's that's relevant I think to now I
understand I think what your original
question was which I guess is the nature
of what this what this parody is which
is that everyone these days on
television probably in this very
building they bring people on and they
fight and they fight out fake points and
there's no actual conversation and
really the people talking usually have
no idea what they're talking about and
that's why they're brought on and it's
quick bytes and its usual drivel
actually if you if you watch CNN an hour
of CNN you will be dumber than when you
started
can we talk about a couple of the issues
that do seem to crop up time time and
again I sure culture wars for example
identity politics is the one that the
one that fascinates me I mean you you're
as a gay man yeah it strikes me a
slightly strange that you rails so much
against the concept of identity politics
when it is pretty clear from having
watched you for quite some time
that your sexuality is central to who
you are I don't think it's cent central
at all actually I mean I happen to be
gay but I don't use that as a grudge
allure a bludgeon against anyone that
I'm arguing with I mean this is why I
talked about the individual all the time
the only thing that matters it has not
whether you're gay or straight or black
or white or female or trans those things
are actually completely irrelevant other
than your thoughts your thoughts and
actions are what matters so I don't come
at anything from I'm a gay man so this
no but it's curious what it's cumulative
though I'm not suggesting that your
sexuality defines entirely yeah who you
are but it clearly has an effect and on
what fascinates me is that you you you
hate that I wouldn't not hate well I
hate identity politics yes you're gonna
go yeah I do hate identity politics
because identity politics is what takes
away your capacity as an individual to
think identity politics is what groups
us you're black you so you should think
this your gauge so you should think this
you're Muslim so you should think this
and then it puts people in this
oppression Olympics and this is where
they this is where intersectionality oh
your oppression and my oppression
together they're stronger but
actually that causes this sort of
competing interest but but identity
politics of this type of person should
get this and we should take from this
person and give to this person and that
we should hate more than anything else
the straight white male is incredibly
dangerous it's actually the complete
antithesis of what our founding
documents were about well with with a
you know with a straight white male in
the white house it does seem like
they're doing okay these days well I'm
not saying they're doing okay are not
doing okay I mean I I jus I would judge
Trump as an individual the same way I
would judge anyone else's individual
okay so where then do you put yourself
on on the political spectrum because you
know you do what if you watch the ribbon
report you might be led down the path of
suggesting that you're on the right of
sent I would say now there's no argument
that I could really make that would
identify me with what the left is now
with what the progressive movement is
with what the Democratic socialists are
socialist Democrats are that has nothing
to do with any of the ideas I care about
if people that are part of that want to
talk to me respectfully and without
personally attacking me and things of
that nature I'm happy to have those
conversations but I'm not part of that
so whether whether I left them or they
shifted so far that the Overton Window
move that they left me out you know I
think it's a little bit of semantics but
but either way what I can tell you is
that I consistently find conservatives
and people on the right open to having
discussions they're willing to debate
abortion they're willing to debate
legalizing marijuana or talking about
gay marriage and they're willing to do
it respectfully and I see virtually none
of that on the modern left when you say
that what do you mean did what they're
just angry that they're unwilling to
concede that well if there's something
wrong in their position yeah and one
well if their strength you're kind of
yeah I mean I yeah I just don't I don't
understand the question really but they
that generally speaking if your default
position is that the people you disagree
with are bigots are racist or homophobic
any leash in a conversation to figure
out what they think you want some of
their will they identifies bigots
exactly that though well if I mean if
you'd have to give me an example if you
do if you told me that someone was did
not want black people to have certain
rights by the nature be
cuz of the nature of the color of their
skin that person is a bigot and should
be called a bigot if you tell me that
someone believes in low taxes and that
makes them a bigot well now we've got a
discussion to have about that so I don't
see generally people on the left being
willing to engage in that set of ideas
and that and that that type of
discussion the left by and large and
what it has become now through academia
and the media is is pretty homogeneous
when it comes to thought they love
diversity they love the idea of
diversity we love black people we love
gay people all of this but they don't
like diversity of thought I mean go be a
go be a black person and try to deviate
from the the progressive group think and
see how quickly they will turn against
you as a black person go be a gay person
and say anything against what the
progressives want you to believe and see
how quickly they'll show you that
they're not really for gay people be a
woman being nikki Haley and happened to
be a Republican woman who I who I think
is pretty spectacular and see how
quickly they're not really for women
because you can't be for groups because
every time you say I'm for a group I'm
for gay people I'm for black people I'm
for women well every time a gay person
or a black person or a woman thinks
differently than you want them to think
well then quickly you're gonna have to
purge them so that that really is the
essence of intolerance
well let's return to that very first
question how does it feel to be the
interviewee rather than the interview
good I like it you know it's it's even
for the stuff that you were challenging
me on it's like this is the point of all
of this this is the this is what people
want they don't want these little
prepackaged things where we can just
fight with each other and I think in a
weird way some of the pushback on me is
people are so dumb down from watching
that for so long that they can't even
believe someone could sit there and be
respectful with someone else who they
may disagree with or may not disagree
with they actually can't believe it
because they've been spoon-fed crap for
so long that when they see something
decent it might be a little off-putting
because it's like what what is that I
don't remember that but you know what
you can go on YouTube and you can find
lots of interviews from the 60s 70s 80s
and 90s done here in the UK
a done done in America where people used
to be respectful so if we live in a time
where everyone's at each other's throats
if if the argument is Dave's too
respectful or or agrees too much I will
gladly take that criticism Dave ribbon
many thanks for being with us yeah my
pleasure